hey 42 here one-sixth of all Google
searches have never been searched before
welcome to RIF when you suck on hard
candy you are basically drinking your
own saliva mixed with flavorings
Hitler's handwriting was impeccable when
famous psychologist Carl Jung saw
Hitler's handwriting
he noted that Hitler's handwriting
suggests that he had highly feminine
instincts only 1% of a tree is actually
alive the other 99% is hardened dead
cells 1.2 trillion dollars of US money
is in circulation but nobody knows where
85% of it is the ice lost in Antarctica
every year will be enough to give every
person on earth 1 million three hundred
and sixty thousand ice cubes it is
possible to travel by zip wire from
Spain to Portugal vegetables are roughly
four times healthier than fruit Sweden
is so good at recycling that they've run
out of rubbish and import 80 thousand
tonnes a year from Norway in fact Sweden
even recycles dead rabbits into biofuel
you are four times more likely to drown
in your bath than you are to die of food
poisoning in 17th century Virginia
missing free Sunday Masses in a row
carried a death sentence
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2